[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 196 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast i
am john and i'm here with my colleague
mark hey Mark how's it going all right
how are you doing Jeff pretty good we
had a pretty long series of trips
together yeah and uh it's kind of good
to you know wind down and just you know
get back to our listeners yeah back in
San Francisco for like I don't know a
couple of weeks and then I'm going back
in yeah so who are you today
yeah we're gonna talk to Jesse Houston
CEO and co-founder of Phoenix labs and
if you guys don't know a Phoenix Labs is
they made several games one of them be
very successful being dauntless and I've
played it quite a bit and it's pretty
cool it's pretty cool game yeah awesome
and then after that we've got our
question of the week as per usual be
asking me what the difference is between
premium versus standard network why
would I use one over the other sounds
good
so let's get into our cool things of the
week let's do that
[Applause]
my first cool thing of the week is
virtual displays for compute engine and
Ogier so what that means is when you
remote into your actual server your
windows instance you can actually create
a virtual display specifically for your
VM that's running its own separate CPU
which is kind of awesome because you
don't have to allocate GPUs for it so
that means that this is gonna be less
expensive very nice awesome
speaking of going gee a cloud native
load balancing on gke is now generally
available so if you're not familiar with
that basically you want to do load
balancing to your containers running on
top of gke this is a more efficient way
of doing so so this is basically what
they call Network endpoint group load
balancing basically it means that your
traffic is going from your load balancer
directly to your container rather than
sort of meandering its way around your
cluster to eventually end up at a pod I
will have a link in the show notes to
the blog post they have a great diagram
explaining this really well but if you
want to get four spin it's no GA that's
awesome our next cool thing comes from
one of our fellow developer advocates
met say awesome oh he has written a blog
post on running a Windows container app
on GCE notice so it's pretty awesome
because if you're getting started
running containers and dealing with
containers and docker this helps you run
a Windows instance and mente really
focuses in targeted dotnet community so
he goes through all of the steps of
creating a container app and then you
know building a docker image and then
deploying on gke so it's kind of Awesome
very nice very cool and last but not
least is a special plug out to well
essentially myself and the rest the team
that works on the icon is project of
course so Agana is the open source
platform for running multiplayer game
servers on top of kubernetes you may
have heard me mention it once or twice
we went 1.0 as of about a week ago
Congrats so this is a really big
milestone which is super cool so we now
have a stable API service and ready from
workloads and we're definitely picking
up a lot more people using in production
so very very exciting stuff for Google
cloud for games awesome
and congratulations why thank you very
much well John why don't we go have a
chat with Jesse and talk all about
Phoenix labs and dollars
[Music]
so this week we are joined by Jesse
Houston CEO and co-founder of Phoenix
labs he is one of the people behind the
hot new game I don't if it's new yeah
that's a good topic Dauntless she's been
doing very well lately but Jesse how are
you doing I am doing really well thanks
mark
excellent excellent so if people who
aren't familiar with you or Phoenix Labs
won't you tell us a little bit about
yourself and what you do yeah so you
gave me the best introduction that I
think I've ever had so yeah I started
Phoenix labs about five years ago now we
have been basically from the beginning
making dauntless dauntless has been out
in its most recent form like it's kind
of wide release you know full access
form since May so we launched on May
21st prior to that we you know did
various kind of rounds of betas from an
open beta last year and then the year
prior to that we kind of had a closed
beta so dauntless has actually been
around for about three years just kind
of you know in various soft launched
forms you know just kind of give you an
idea of what dauntless is because I you
know I always speak like everybody knows
so it's called a hunting action game
it's about you and your friends getting
together on any platform coming together
fighting big monsters that we call
behemoths you know and then you kind of
collect their bits and you go back into
the city and you hang out and you forge
new weapons and armor and you go back
and kill bigger scarier kind of these
big boss encounters I remember the open
beta when it was at Google cloud next
last year that was my first Nix so I do
remember the beta you did mention that
you can pretty much play with your
friends on any platform so that I'm
assuming that's cross-platform yeah
right yeah so we're like the third game
ever to allow we call kind of the one
dauntless experience so the idea of you
know if you're on PC and I'm on Xbox and
Mark is on ps4 we could all play
together and that you guys could switch
consoles and it would be just totally
just fine where it's a pretty crazy
thing but we love the fact that not only
can we play together but we can be on
each other trends lists and you know we
can swap back and forth and that kind of
stuff just to be clear I'm a PC gamer
good so I just I can't play games on me
the controller I can't do it it's funny
I actually play dauntless with a
controller on PC Oh interesting
then like certain types of games like
that I just ended up looking at the sky
or the floor and that's just my life
cool
so since you said like you've been
running dauntless for over three years
it's an online multiplayer game so I see
in the industry oh god I don't want to
say that that's a hopeful but like we
refer to that it's kind of like a live
service online game like is an ongoing
game what what's that like can tell us a
little bit about like what is a live
service game and like what is the
experience of running it like you know
we knew from the get-go that we wanted
to be a live service game yeah we call
it a life service game too and so
literally from the first line of code
written or the first submit anyways into
perforce had to come with a deployment
step and so we started running dedicated
servers like four years ago
initially it was a total mess you know
we do these things called holiday builds
where we used to do them when we're
still in a really closed state where you
know we try and get everything and just
before the holidays and then well we did
the studio closure
everybody would play and I can remember
in it goes 2015 holiday build myself and
the technical director basically did
12-hour shifts through the entire
holiday writing Python scripts just to
keep the game from falling over with
like a hundred and fifty people playing
not at the same time like period like
ten people playing and like the you know
we did have to do like manual log
rotations and all this other stuff
you know that kind of experience really
taught us all of the things that we
needed kind of progressively as as we
launched and so there's a lot of stuff
on May 21st that went wrong but a lot of
stuff that actually went really right
because you know we have been doing it
kind of progressively bigger and having
never turned the servers off in four
years really helps kind of just get used
to it you know a lot of companies that
go into the live environment tend to
have to all of a sudden slow down
because they're like oh what is updating
whereas you know it's no big deal in the
last two weeks we've patched five times
and you know most players only sell one
patch for example like a lot of our
stuff doesn't need to take a game
service down all the time and it's been
a great learning experience either way
that's the best way to go not having to
actually turn off your game in order to
get a patch you know doesn't really mean
any downtime because I hate those games
where you have updates if the wait three
hours and I'm like now what I do at my
life it's been really interesting
that experience by the way like Xbox and
PlayStation don't have tools to support
that kind of experience of like the no
downtime deploys and so we've gotten the
opportunity to work with them and kind
of do a little bit of teaching on our
own on what that experience can feel
like and that it's okay and that that
doesn't mean that there's going to be
rampant hacking or some sort of other
vulnerabilities like down timing and
deploying don't need to be the same
thing and you know it's actually been a
really cool experience getting to kind
of introduce gamers on these platforms
to that experience let's go back a
little bit and talk about going from 150
gamers to you know a full launch let's
talk about scaling can you tell us a
little bit how your team went about
scaling this to support you know a
full-time launch and then you've gone
from 150 to God knows how many players
you have now you know initially when we
did everything it was all you know
everything was super manual so you know
we would deploy a VM manually upload a
build and initially it was like on
Windows boxes only and you know it was
all like put your eyepiece in by hand
and that kind of stuff and then we
basically kind of just kept iterating to
you know add more and more automation
through the processes and then as you're
flexing that natural adding more players
stuff just you know kind of breaks and
so a lot of our kind of scaling efforts
were around you know just fixing what
was broken and making sure that like
we're then able to see you know into the
future far enough that we could kind of
see the next most vulnerable thing like
more recently you know the sequel
databases you know there's a bunch of
like our inventory was on SQL and you
know we had millions and millions of
players showing up every day and you
know just the transaction rates were
just way too high for whatever sequel
was ever gonna be able to handle until
we were able to move over to BigTable
and we had to do that in a no downtime
world as well so it was like super
exciting like you know having to write
basically a service that would shut
BigTable and if it wasn't there then go
get it from sequel and then loaded into
BigTable and then give the response back
to players and that kind of stuff and so
you know through that whole experience
though we've basically been like okay
well that's the next thing that's gonna
fall over
let's go and harden it or read architect
it or what-have-you and we've gone from
like you know hardcore V
based kind of call it like 2014-2015
thought processes on how stateful game
servers should run to you know almost
everything now runs in kubernetes we
were able to basically load a bunch of
stateful services into that and now all
of our game servers for example are in
Kate's and you know that's been hugely
helpful because we don't have to worry
about things like VM Management nearly
as much as I okay cool fire up a pod put
some players on it you know if the pod
has a problem no big deal it can die and
you know it doesn't take down dozens and
dozens of players it only you know
affects for and whereas like
historically if a VM died which you know
what happened once or twice a day it
could take down thousands of players and
so we don't have that problem anymore so
we've been you know super lucky that
we've just been kind of able to iterate
that way
nice can you give us a sense of that
like yeah John mentioned like scale like
can you share numbers about like a
bigger player base you have or at least
any general yeah so you know I think
we've announced it so hopefully we have
otherwise my PR guys gonna come at me
with a lightning bolt but we've got
about 15 million players who are
actively playing Dauntless a great group
of folks and that's kind of across the
three platforms and you know we're
moving into switch next which we're
really excited about all those new
players coming in and then mobile kind
of in the next year or so fantastic yeah
I'm actually getting it on switch it's
so good
surprisingly great experience so yeah I
mean you've mentioned dedicated game
servers mm-hmm do you have like a
variety of different back-end services
or like what is that sort of
architecture look like a little bit so
it's entirely inside of like do you
speak and you know we basically have
when a user logs in there's a bunch of
you know various kind of a combination
of both rest based and a RPC calls that
happen to various services and you know
those are like a combination of Java and
Python
you know micro services that live in in
Kate's and then once you kind of gone
through all of that stuff we drop you on
to like a big Hema heavy C++ based game
server that manages most of you know
what you experience as a player from
what the behemoth is doing and kind of
where you're at what the city looks like
that kind of thing and so each of those
pods will have anywhere from you know
four to 50 players on them and at a
given time and there
two big ones there's a concept of like a
city and then an island server and
they're different because you know like
one requires a behemoth and the other
one requires lots of players and so we
kind of keep them somewhat separate and
then the others this like cloud of other
services around it from you know
inventory to store management to you
know persistent data storage to you know
telemetry and analytics and stuff like
that and largely kind of we shim a lot
of calls from basically the client the
servers and we kind of farm it out to
other Google services from like bigquery
and that kind of stuff fun I would
imagine that there has to be some type
of reasoning for taking this type of
approach and going for using these
back-end services so I'm not sure if you
want to share like your secret sauce as
to why you made these design choices you
know we're pretty lucky this isn't the
first time that we have built like a
scalable game surface we got a lot of
folks from you know myself from Riot
we've got some folks from EA we've got
some folks from PopCap and so we kind of
brought together a bunch of learnings
from previous call it big triple-a
experiences and you know as we thought
about how we've historically built stuff
you know there's always those lists you
make at the end of any given kind of
product cycle we're like man I wish next
time I would totally do it like this you
know in the forefront of that has always
been kind of horizontal scaling you know
if I look back to kind of some of my
previous games you know there's always
that one surface that's super monolithic
and we try and just throw more RAM at it
or more CPUs and there's just no way you
know hey this story a few times away you
know and we've done that too let's
rewrite it in C++ it's fine yeah exactly
right like you know there's a couple of
Redis boxes lying around in our platform
still that are very warm at any given
time and that's not a knock on reddit's
by the way that like Redis is amazing
and has what's good uses we've just been
like it's scales infinitely on that one
thread so you know as we kind of came
together and architected it you know we
knew that we wanted to get a lot more
horizontal scaling in and so you know we
just kind of keep looking for that and
also like you know if you think back to
kind of like the 2012 days and you know
through to kind of 2015 the industry was
still very much nascent in terms of
cloud hosting you know who's still
considered a bad idea and you know
especially on stuff like you know the
idea of DevOps I can try to remember
when the Phoenix project was actually
written but like the idea of DevOps for
example is completely unknown and you
know things that continuous delivery in
terms of you know a live product service
we're still only things that like Google
and Facebook could do and it's an indie
studio there's you know there's no way
and you know we've been really lucky in
that you know we're now at a time in the
industry where a lot of those kind of
processes are well thought through and
you know they make sense in kind of core
product loops and players are also
willing to get into the mindset of oh if
I give feedback today tomorrow I might
see that change or even faster like so
we did a big deploy yesterday and you
know one of the players was like hey
this one quest line doesn't unlock this
thing and thirty minutes later we
deployed the fix and you know he's like
oh wow like that's bloody amazing and
like no that's you know that's the cool
part of what 2019 can provide yes that's
a particular interest of mine personally
you chose kubernetes and gke
specifically even for running dedicated
game servers which is not publicly
something that people talk about why did
you why did you make that decision you
know one of the big problems that come
with games server hosting is the buffer
warmth you know there's all the game
servers that you've got in use and then
stuff that's currently turned off and
then stuff that's not in use but has to
be turned on to handle any kind of
matchmaking spikes that happen right and
my historical life has taught me that if
I'm doing this in stack and Rockland you
know I have to be able to have enough
capacity for my spikes and I have to
leave them turned on all the time and
I'm paying the bills on all of these
boxes and if I'm living in kind of VM
land you know VMs can take you know
initially like a Windows VM could take
up to two or three minutes to provision
and so we always had to have call it
five minutes of buffer at any given time
and if you think about Dauntless like
dollars's experience can be as low as
three minute game sessions right so
waiting around for five minutes to have
capacity is really bad so we have to
keep quite a bit more buffer than that
and you know things like garbage
collection like services that we
Sall in these boxes can take a while
like just cleaning up logs and like
getting replays off the boxes and all
this other stuff and making sure
everything's in the same state those
processes could take you know upwards of
five minutes as well and so you know
we'd have to keep you know call it ten
or fifteen percent extra capacity online
at any given time whereas in gke I
basically can keep like one percent
extra capacity online I just need to
make sure that there are no completely
full boxes at all and given how rapid
the pods come on and offline like
there's this nice kind of automatic load
balancing that ends up happening and so
I've actually I just you know I keep it
tight a little bit of buffer and it's
also super nice it spills over so like
if we got it like a crazy spike like I
don't know you know if an outage happens
for example on one region no big deal
like players and spillover we could very
very very very quickly spin up capacity
elsewhere and there can be a really nice
tight integration with our matchmaker so
that players don't even notice Houston
so I'm curious because when dauntless
launched I'm assuming that you know now
we're in 2019 you know everything's run
in the cloud what is like the trickiest
part of scaling a game I've seen much as
goals and then immediately servers went
down because they're anticipating with
numbers oh that happened with us we had
all sorts of fun exciting times I mean
so we knew a lot of more players are
going to show up you know you're into
consoles there's kind of like a
validation moment that happens without
all this PR rolling up with all these
influencers so we know that there's a
bunch more players showing up and each
problem that games have that and love
but I hate is that there's not really a
nice easy way of load testing without
real humans and so finding a quarter
million humans or whatever to come and
log into a game before it's launched is
literally impossible and so you know we
need to basically kind of think about
that the new way and so you know we did
all the usual stuff with load testing
like you know every service has like a
locust thing which is like flaps the
living heck out of every end point and
we saw what we thought our load could be
you know but that's still not
representative and so we were able to
actually basically analyze what real
players did in the closed beta and use
that data to inform BOTS and then cool
parts about communities as we were then
able to like spin up literally hundreds
of thousands of BOTS to play down like
kind of like headless like they were
still real accounts just they didn't
have
and they knew what to do because they
represented real-life players and so we
were able to just like spin up thousands
and thousands and thousands of them and
so that actually got us a ton of really
good information and then it started
shutting off our video game and we
couldn't figure out why and so like the
Thursday before launch
every time that we did a bot test that
had more than 40,000 people playing and
it would shut off products you know we'd
be running it in a different environment
and then all of a sudden prod would shut
off and we couldn't cope why turns out
by the way that when you write a botnet
anti botnet protections that you put in
place work exactly so that took a long
time for us to figure out what was wrong
you know these groups that you work with
to write these protections part of how
they do it is they like cut off all
communication yeah so we basically DDoS
ourselves into submission right through
the day before launch finally kind of
got that fixed you know and then the
fact is like the play patterns changed
and a lot more people showed up than we
ever expected you know probably three or
four times more folks showed up than any
of our expectations congratulations
thank you yeah like great great first
world problem to have right but we're
really really really really concerned
with delivering a great experience and
so you know a lot of what we were trying
to do at that point then was you know
trying to get ourselves back up running
as fast as possible setting up things
like BigTable and moving a lot of our
databases over to BigTable and you know
as well as trying to communicate
effectively and then you know inching up
cool well what if we let 10,000 more
players and alright cool we inch that up
okay what's the next thing like starts
to become unstable the launch week
between Tuesdays at Tuesday we did
seventeen hundred and twelve deploys Wow
I thought you were so like kind of
watching this from the sidelines as a
fan of CCP games and I thought that you
did something I thought was actually
really cool in terms of like you you
capture players at certain points and
then only like allowed certain numbers
in and had a queueing system that was
something I don't think I've seen many
other people do and I thought that was
really interesting he took us through
that you know some of the other games
that I've worked on in the past what
what ends up happening when you know the
services get full is they just kind of
keep layering them in there and having a
you know semi degraded service until the
whole thing kind of cascades over and so
our thought process was what if there
was a very thin version of the game
spoke just enough of the language of the
servers to basically leave them in a
queue and you know have enough call
homes that scaled wildly and so like and
what if we made it some that could take
a hundred times our wildest dreams of
players the queue itself for example is
you know coming back to rent us it was
basically a little Python app that had
like five hundred lines of code that
just touched a Redis box and had kind of
you know whenever he got put in queue
depending on where you are in the
Kealing it would basically say to the
client you know hey cool come check back
in in X number of seconds here's where
you are in line at one point I think we
had three hundred thousand players in
queue and you know we were accepting
like fifty players a second or something
like that into the game and so like that
he was quite long and just the act of
checking the queue would have taken down
the service all by itself and so we
actually had to kind of write in this
graceful kind of fall off or whatever so
that would only check back in once every
three or four minutes when you were you
know more than an hour in queue and that
kind of thing the nice thing about that
too is we can also overload the messages
that the queue would tell players like
if something was really going wrong we
could you know we could change the text
in that box and say hey you know we're
having this other problem so ketones are
gonna be even longer and that kind of
thing and that's been really really
helpful oh nice and then anybody that
actually made it through the queue got a
reward these little titles that are in
your game so we also recorded all the
player shoots at the queue made it
through and so a message that you would
get like the error code was called Queen
B queue blocked and so the title that
you get in the game is the slayer of the
Queen saw something so I could imagine
that given all of the things you had to
go through at launch that there had to
be some people that you had to reach out
on our end to actually help you with the
launch and any type of other integration
that you had to do so I'm curious about
how our professional teams helped you
out and I'm not sure exactly which teams
you actually met with but oh you know
hopefully to speak to that just a bit
yeah for sure so we've had a great
relationship with the GCP folks since
open beta launch actually like our
Account Manager was there when I pushed
the big button on open beta 18 months
ago or whatever and he actually brought
the champagne and so you know we
basically kind of got the opportunity to
work with like the CRE team and you know
the GCP Technical Account Managers and
the service account managers and
like that through the build-up to launch
and that gave us a lot of insight of
what could fall over and what couldn't
the weekend before launch when we were
running into the we don't know why our
game isn't turned on because we're
ddossing ourselves for example we had
five folks from CRT and from the GCP
technical team on site and they stayed
up all night with us helping you know we
set up desks in the war room we have
basically a big kind of common space in
the studio that we normally use for
mocap we basically set up a 15 desk and
then as launch happened everybody was on
site with us helping call the shots we
had kind of a dedicated Google hangout
PC with a big monitor that was kind of
pointing into the room that folks from
Google could phone in and help and at
one point we had something like 50
Googlers supporting us during the launch
it was really awesome you know I have
the opportunity of working on a
relatively cool thing like working on
games is kind of interesting and so you
know as folks kind of heard that we were
doing this thing and like at one point
we had folks from like the GCP Linux
kernel team heard that we were having a
kernel panic issue because of you know
some reason and next thing I know I got
some dude that understands how all that
crazy business works and he's right and
kernel patches for us you know just
because it's interesting and he couldn't
login and he's like we're gonna fix your
kernel panics and it's like great let's
go it was really wild folks coming in
from all over the place you know we got
custom versions of the kubernetes
masters written for us because we were
putting load on the masters like no one
at Google had ever seen and you know we
were basically turning on and off so
many pods per second like at one point
like our master was getting something
like 2,500 requests per second and like
two orders of magnitude bigger than
Google had ever seen before even on
their own services and they're like well
okay I guess we have to make a snowflake
version as it was called for you guys
and so it was super supportive
everybody from capacity planning we were
you know 3x off what our craziest
numbers were and so you know we have the
capacity planning folks phone again
going like just finding servers for us
and every time that we would find
servers eight hours later the problems
shifted to a new area of the world and
so they're coming back online to find us
more servers for throughout the world
and it was a really awesome experience
overall yeah that sounds great
I'd love to know as well like even more
about that CRE experience
were they highlighting things that
you're like this stuff is amazing and
then were they like this part they're
like I don't know or like what did that
what did that whole like thing look like
as you engage you cieariy
yeah over there kind of the six months
towards launch they would come on-site
and take a look at our tech stack with
us take a look at the usage patterns and
go you know hey have you thought about
maybe not using like cloud sequel for
all of your often inventory yeah it's
gonna be fine like we load tested to
like you know eight million bazillion
and they're like yeah cool no that's not
gonna work now we don't need BigTable
like you know the old ways that's the
right stuff no no no it's not the right
stuff okay sure cool then you know sure
enough yeah its though is the wrong
choice BigTable is the right way but you
know a lot of it was just them kind of
coming on site being able to leverage
all of this kind of institutional
knowledge that's built up at Google and
with other partners and really kind of
just poke you know really gentle holes
in what we were building and our thought
processes and like giving us a lot more
context but and we basically just kind
of came up with this very you know
prioritized list of stuff that we needed
to fix and the issues that we had on May
21st or just the next stuff that we
couldn't get to in time which was really
like super awesome because the stuff
that was way above there was way harder
to fix so you know stuff that we could
turn around and under a day you ended up
being with stuff and so they basically
continued to pay attention through the
launch and started projecting out going
like hey you know you know as an example
we were using so again in sequel sequel
it's like the bane of our existence I
think you know we are doing binary logs
for all of our transactions and at one
point you know we got a call I think it
was on Friday after launch going cool so
you're gonna run out of hard disk space
on the largest instance that Google can
make just do two binary logs for your
whole service is gonna fall over in
three days it's no problem
it's like cool effect God you called
we've got three days all right how do we
fix this and it's just been that kind of
thing where you know while we were kind
of eyes deep in kind of the immediate
fire you know the CRT team ended up just
kind of having
one week plus out perspective and spent
time coming up with solutions to like
okay cool instead of this do this other
thing
and when it got really crazy they opened
up various editors and we're supporting
us directly so it was pretty cool that
sounds awesome
glad you could cooperate what a lot of
people and it's kind of funny how games
bring people together isn't it yeah
right
like you know we always talk about that
in the product side but never in the
development side
hey at least none of the companies that
I've ever worked with before had call it
the presence of mind or the openness to
invite other companies to support and it
was really sweet getting to work with
Google on the fact that because they
were just like you know will happily
come into your house and help you just
open the door and we're like yeah like
come on in I beg you so it was a good
experience that's awesome so I'm curious
if you could do this all again
I mean grant said you let us into your
house yeah what is the one thing that
you would do differently was one thing
you could possibly change if you have
something you know that's such a weird
loaded question because the way I look
at that is like what didn't we see the
assumption there is that you know that
I'm smarter today than I was yesterday
or that I had inherently bad judgment
then I don't think I would have changed
anything given the knowledge that we had
I think we did a really good job you
know I think if I could have seen or you
know learned something ahead of time you
know I think I would have liked to have
done a better job with log management I
know that's really explicit but like
there were a couple of things that took
a little longer for us to identify
because of how we did log management as
an example like you know it took a long
time for us to get load testing back
online because we didn't know we were
ddosing ourselves that was in the logs
from the first outage we just didn't see
it we didn't know what to look for we
didn't know what to read you know these
415 errors that were getting spun up it
wasn't until you know I think it was
Sunday night or Monday really really
early in the morning that one of our
engineers it's like what's it or 4:15 I
don't know you know Google search away
you know you know but it took like
multiple days before we got to because
we were just like we just didn't do a
good job there the other thing that I
think I would do personally differently
is you know Mike I don't think my career
really taught me a lot about crisis
management interesting and so you know
in the like minutes of sleep that I was
getting or like the minutes of downtime
that I was getting post-launch I was
doing a lot of reading about like how
firefighters actually manage crisis and
you know even just that small amount of
learning that I got in that week in
terms of like I noticed a thing okay
cool like who did this really well okay
firefighters do okay quick go find
literally a textbook on how to be a fire
captain and how to think about you know
how to put a burning house out and how
to tell folks to go and do the right
work just that a little bit of extra
knowledge was really critical and if I
could have learned something ahead of
time that I'm more intelligent about now
I would have liked to have been better
at crisis management just as a general
like leadership trait a lot of you know
leadership folks and like technical
leadership like manuals and and blog
posts and all this other stuff talked a
lot about like you know vision and
empowerment and you know all this other
stuff that you know I ascribe to really
massively but on the other hand like
when you know for lack of a better term
when hitting the fan and the building's
literally on fire it's a very different
set of skills than trying to expose a
vision and getting up in front of teams
and this kind of stuff and it definitely
highlighted a personal weakness for me
where you know just literally like
keeping focused on task on the right
stuff and not you know accidentally
getting people into a flailing place and
that kind of stuff I'm continuing to
invest more of my kind of my personal
growth time on that kind of stuff
awesome what's coming next can you tell
us about what's coming next or anything
yeah cool there's a lot of really cool
stuff coming we just announced our next
weapon with Nintendo so we're obviously
coming to switch this year not many
months left in this year so it's soon
it's a lot of fun we just showed it at
PAX there's a whole bunch of new
expansion content coming up we're like
you know the way I kind of described it
we're just getting started like you know
we'll probably kind of come out of kind
of early access or whatever we're
calling the game right now
soonish and just kind of keep pumping in
more value into it like team is ripping
and raring to go or however that saying
is something like that okay
before you go is there anything that we
missed that you might want to mention
you're gonna be anywhere particularly
you want people to come find you or
anything like that you know obviously
anybody who's keen on dauntless like
feel free to give it a try at play
dauntless calm
I personally I'm gonna be giving some
talks over at the Montreal international
game summit in November on kind of
leadership and growing teams and
companies and lessons learned and that
kind of stuff you know otherwise like
you know we've got a bunch of GC talks
as well that we've done that are
recorded on kind of how we scale
dauntless now we built it feel free to
check those out they're really cool
awesome so I have one personal question
before we let you go cuz oh you're
probably this second CEO of a game that
I've talked to you how many hours have
you have logged in dauntless oh my god
how many hours have I logged in
dauntless thank God we don't have a
slash played command like you know
probably more than I'd like to admit it
we used to actually have this counter at
the studio for number of drastic kills
so drastic is like this kind of big
green scaly lightning lizard thing it
was the first kind of production quality
behemoth we had I was the first at the
studio to a thousand kills and those
fights used to take 20 minutes long so
and then I stopped letting us use the
counter because it was either
non-productive or life destroying one of
the two probably not the the most played
version since May at the studio for sure
that probably goes to like either
Quinton one of our web devs or maybe 10
or one of our artists they you know
Quentin's like max level gear on
everything and he rivals some of our
best streamers now I can punch with the
best but I'm like not as much as I used
to sadly fantastic all right thank you
so much for hanging out with us today
that's been a pleasure talking to you
well hey it's my pleasure thank you so
much for having me
see you alright guys so we want to give
a big thank you to Jesse Houston for
joining us on this week's podcast very
very interesting conversation on how
dauntless and Phoenix labs got started
on GCE
other headaches they've gotten all the
things they had to go through and it's
kind of awesome to see one of our
success stories especially in games
absolutely so let's get into our
question of the week
so our question that week is what is the
difference between premium and standard
Network this is a good question so this
is fun so way back in the day there was
but one network and there was only one
network to choose and that was what we
currently referred to now as premium
tier networking so the short answer here
is the way Google's network works is we
try and get you onto our network as fast
as possible so we have a whole bunch of
fiber and it runs out of the water and
all that kind of cool stuff so we
basically try and get you from your
internet service provider directly to
our points of presence we have like over
a hundred round the world and then get
you inside the Google Network where we
can control everything it runs over a
network and it works really nicely this
is this is the premium tier this is
basically high-performance routing we're
able to do some other things like have a
cloud load balancing to be global PI of
global SLA is things like that this is
basically what you want when you want
performance super fast but what we also
have is what we call standard tier which
is very similar to basically what a lot
of other cloud providers provide wherein
you spend the vast majority of your time
over the public Internet so you're not
running over our network it's gonna be a
little slower you can have a little bit
less of a consistent experience but it's
cheaper this is where we're not gonna
try and get you on our network as fast
as possible we're gonna leave you on the
public network and so you're gonna be on
a low performance tier but it is cheaper
so maybe if cost is what you're trying
to optimize for the standard tier could
be really good but if speed is what
you're looking for then the premium tier
could be really good and you can choose
either one as you see fit for each
workload as you require it so really
depends on what your needs are awesome
so Marc yes where are you gonna be going
where am I going what am i doing that's
a good question so first I'm going on
vacation in a few weeks so I'm very
excited about that well deserved well I
hope so yes we'll ever do so I'm doing
that and then after I get back from
vacation I will be a cube con as I know
you will be as well yes I will
I believe we're doing some workshops for
bellisima ganas and some open match
workshops for anyone who works like
games industry probably floating around
at a bunch of talks and stuff like that
as well literally I just got back from
finishing a bunch of other things so I
haven't actually make it all my plans
for coop gone yet there's more stuff
coming I'm sure but come and say hi
either way and I also will be a Q Khan
and I will be doing all of the above
that mark just mentioned yeah
and I will be attending several weddings
in the upcoming months
all my friends decided to get married
together so that means more flying that
works that works oh yeah we'll make sure
we have some global platform podcast
stickers especially I need to bug one of
our friends April and make sure that we
have some organized and open mesh
stickers to hand out as well I
definitely need the new open match one
yeah definitely all right whoa John
thank you very much for joining me on
the episode this week thank you very
much it's been a pleasure as always and
we would like to thank you all for
listening on this episode have a good
time and see you next week see you later
[Music]
you